April where have you been over two phone
calls came in uninvited we're raising
money for my college education Ron I
took a second job back at my old job
do you want to shoeshine two hundred
dollars laugh all you want Kyle I
already took the money out your wallet
oh good news son you have just won a Ron
Swanson scholarship I don't think so I
don't remember applying already wrong
Swanson Scott wait are you serious stop
this
no stop or you lose the money here I
didn't know what to bring you so I just
got some magazines and lipstick woman's
stuff Thanks
well my parents got me was that okay
well I'm not very good at visiting
people in hospitals so I'm going to go
hey if you see Andy will you not tell
him I'm here okay because of what
happened I don't want him to things up
don't want to know the less I know about
other people's affairs the happier I am
I'm not interested in caring about
people I once worked with a guy for
three years and never learned his name
best friend I ever had
we still never talk sometimes beer Garth
um wasn't sticker outfit collie was the
fourth round Indianapolis Colts know how
to draft so well they really do Andy
this was delicious it's awesome it's a
whole new meat delivery system thank you
so we say we go out to the parking lot
run a few pass plays to burn off the
calories you are an unstoppable good
idea machine I like Andy I'm surrounded
by a lot of women in this department and
that includes the man
look up
hey man reading the defense Reggie wait
[Laughter]
there I think I got it yep you got it ah
do you least tell me what you're doing
I'm a homeowner I would like to actually
learn something yeah I'm tightening the
valve stem into the valve shank I'm
replacing the handle and then tightening
the set screw to hold it in place no oh
my god that's a good feeling
sense of accomplishment and pride damn
it I just love it so much
are you okay
great I'm gonna go around this house and
fix everything I can find that needs
fixing you want to help I really do good
that's next excuse us nice form son make
sure you keep a firm pressure on the
cranium on the cranium all right listen
up I have to turn off the power for one
minute we're gonna go dark people bear
with us okay we got to switch off the
main fuse hose it's just a fuse it's
just a fuse people just a fuse I've seen
you got the handle on that torque wrench
yeah well the flange was a little warped
so I just goosed it with the triple 3
bolt smack that was nonsense
I know but it's so fun to talk like that
you know what keep this
you earned it thanks Ron I would like to
volunteer to do the park survey myself
Wow Ron I always knew there would be a
day when I would get through to you
and you would love government work today
is that historic day yes that is what
has happened spending the day outside
alone sounds like a dream I love being a
father but there are a few things I miss
silence the absence of noise one single
moment undisturbed by the sounds of a
children's TV program called doc
McStuffins
there is no quiet anymore there is only
doc McStuffins
can I ask you kind of an important
question you know like when you go to
the ATM and you get money is there an
actual guy standing behind the wall who
slides dollar bills in there no yeah
this robots Oh actually you know what I
do have a serious question in a movie
predator can you rub any kind of mud on
yourself
to prevent predator from seeing you with
his thermal heat signature site or is it
oh that sucks
are you hurt no all good all good
oops except for my mouth oh whoa
five-second rule no aah come on we'd
better get you to a dentist
the receptionist says she'll fit you in
as soon as there's an opening if you're
alright I'm gonna head back to the park
quickly do you know what my social
security numbers or if I'm allergic to
anything
I don't like corn except for that down
or will that be confusing because I do
like candy corn Oh Ron or a mess
here let me help you all I wanted was
two hours where I got to forget that I
was a parent look I found all three
differences those are two completely
different pictures yeah the numbers
don't lie I'm a goof it's not a gallant
been here forever
can we go don't you want to get your
tooth fixed I don't know I think my
tooth looks fine just like this well my
grandmother was missing that tooth and
she was the most beautiful woman on her
oil rig you are an adult I'm not sure
dad if you want to go we can go yay
thanks Ron that's why you know even
though you're not my dad you're like old
brother to me hey a cool uncle but old
like a grandpa but cool like a son ow ow
ow Andrew you need to get your tooth
fixed no way I'm not going back there I
already won all the magazine mazes don't
worry it's gonna be fine
ow if you don't take care of the problem
now it's only gonna get worse come on
I'll Drive you back fine let me just
walk down this peanut brittle real quick
why would you do that all right cuz
calories I'll be out here if you need me
thanks for doing this Ron when it's all
said and done there or a few mazes I've
cheated on me also the inside of my
mouth is black and hot so let's strip
down to my underwear or all the way
naked hello Diane I'm coming home soon
to relieve you give you a little break
it's no trouble at all I'm a parent I'm
always on duty what flavor ice cream
would you and the children like I'm
getting some for a 30 year older works
for me so I can bring some home for you
too okay let's just even things out
they're now neither of you has a tiara
problem solved it's November 8th yes
well these girls didn't get a chance to
go trick-or-treating so somewhere in
this house there is some candy why don't
you find it and we'll get right out of
your hair hold on one second
you having fun ladies
all right I got some calcium chews and
roll of cookie know what do you say
girls appreciate it
do you fish April no fish up close let
me give you a piece of fishing advice
instead I don't when you have a fish on
the line
you don't just drag it behind the boat
you either reel it in or you cut him
loose especially if he's a nice fish
with a big lovable fish heart you don't
know what you're talking about maybe not
maybe you really do hey Tandy maybe
moving to indianapolis just to get
revenge on him is a really good idea
what do I know hey Ron hey Ron
ladies ladies
[Applause]
you